it's great to welcome Andrew Torres back
to the program today he's a graduate of
Harvard Law who has been practicing law
for 21 years also co-host of the opening
arguments show a legal podcast that
helps you make sense of the news and at
the top of that list for me right now
Andrew is net neutrality net neutrality
an issue that is political it is a legal
issue it is an issue in so many
different ways and I guess to start us
off one question is we know that we knew
when Donald Trump selected Ajit pi to
run the FCC that repealing net
neutrality was going to be a priority
does a Jeep I need to give justification
for the repeal of net neutrality or if
that's what the FCC wants to do can they
just sort of do it well the the answer
to that is it is kind of both so first
David thanks for having me back on the
show I had a lot of fun last time this
is great
second the FCC is going through what
they call a rulemaking set of set of
procedures and so yes they do have to
make findings and the FCC also has to
open up those findings for a period of
public notice and comment which is in
fact you know what they've done so the
the this preliminary decision to reverse
net neutrality was actually made in May
of 2017 it was a two-to-one vote and
over the rather strenuous objection of
Commissioner Clyburn
and then as a result of that vote the
FCC said that they were going to do
really two things number one they were
going to eliminate the 2015 open
Internet order passed by Obama's FCC
that classified Internet service
providers as title to common carriers
and we can talk about what that means in
a minute and then number two they wanted
to open up for comment and the precise
language was to seek comment on whether
to keep modify or eliminate the
bright-line rules that were set forth in
that in that order and then after
the comment period which received as far
as I can tell a record number of
comments for any agency this was it was
highlighted on on John Oliver show and
others and so 22 million people filed
comments I'm guessing that most of those
people did not file comments that said
yes please trash the the the clear
bright line rules but nevertheless from
May to to to the end of November
the FCC moved its position from consider
whether to eliminate those rules to
eliminate those rules and as far as the
comments because I think this is an
interesting thing the FCC needs to be
open to and and accept comments and we
reported earlier in the week about how a
number of the comments over a million of
the comments actually in favor of
getting rid of net neutrality seemed to
have been astroturf or fake comments in
some way shape or form but that aside
just because the FCC has to be open to
receiving comments do they actually need
to go make decisions based on the
consensus from those comments or the
plurality of what the comments want or
do they just need to receive them and
then they can still move however they
want no it's the latter right and that's
why I said the answer to your question
was both so they do have to follow those
procedures but once they admit the
comments they can disregard them which
is which is very clearly what's
happening so as far as title two and the
classification of Internet as common
carriers I think that this is a very
interesting discussion but one that I
feel has a pretty clear answer and in
fact on our Friday show when we answer
questions from the audience someone
wrote in and they said to me hey David
in prota if net neutrality is repealed
in protest
are you willing to cancel your internet
service and if not then why why would
anyone care because you're just gonna
continue paying Comcast for your
internet and that got me thinking I
really only have access to Comcast
Internet where our studio is in Boston
and I need that in order to do my show
so isn't it doesn't that suggest that it
really should be regulated as a utility
it's not a luxury for me to hire Comcast
to provide me the service I need to have
the service in order to do the show
so I think that's a valid argument I
think there are a lot of good arguments
for treating ISPs as title to common
carriers but the legal implication what
happens when you classify something as a
common carrier is you remove it it's
it's it's actually a removal of
jurisdiction from the Federal Trade
Commission and the FTC Act of 1914 which
gives the FTC the power to regulate
quote unfair methods of competition in
or affecting commerce right now
obviously that can be anything but prior
to the 2015 open Internet order there
were lawsuits that was a TC vs. AT&T
that that were brought against AT&T for
deceptive trade practices namely
throttling mobile internet service
right so a a net neutrality type claim
is cognizable under the FTC Act and in
fact that the open Internet order of
2015 resulted in that lawsuit being
mooted and then dismissed in favor of of
AT&T because with ISPs being regulated
as common carriers they were no longer
subject to the jurisdiction of the FTC
so I don't mean to suggest it's a good
thing I I think the arguments for
treating them as a as a title to common
carrier are strong and I think you you
sort of laid that out but I want to
point out that that that's not to me
that's not the real harm of what the FCC
is about to do it's going to make it
more confusing it's going to turn
jurisdiction back over to the FTC the
the FCC is going to take their hands off
but but that doesn't spell the death
knell for being able to use the internet
as as we've come to know it in and of
itself what really hurts I think are the
repeal of the rules so let's talk about
some of those how should you be thinking
through that and you know I every time I
read a statement from an internet
service provider or some of the lobbying
groups that are that are working with
these internet service providers a lot
of times you'll hear them say things
like listen you don't have to worry
because it's not to the advantage of
these ISPs to start either throttling or
creating slow and fast lanes or whatever
they would never do that and I find that
not even worthy of analysis because
shouldn't we be concerned with what
could be done legally it isn't that the
bigger concern than whether we believe
that the current executives of a company
do or don't have an interest in doing it
isn't that what contract law is all
about what could you do yeah so number
one I think the argument isn't a good
argument because we know I mean AT&T
previously excuse me Verizon previously
restricted access to Google Wallet in
ability 2014 so this is this is not just
something that is speculative it's
something that is PS want to do and will
do if they have the power to do so and
the backlash is you know is muted enough
right and and and then secondarily I
think that argument right we can talk
about the throttling and the paid
prioritization the faster and slower
lanes but a key component of the of the
the 2015 open Internet rule was no
interference with edge providers right
and so edge providers are people like
you and I right we are delivering a
service that is carried over the ISP to
end-users that also includes much larger
edge providers like Netflix and and so
forth and and and presently the net
neutrality rules prevent ISPs which own
edge providers from discriminating
against which edge providers they carry
over their lines repealing that that
particular rule I mean I I just can't I
can't come up with a scenario under
which you could convince a company that
it's not in their interest to deny
access to their competitor and so you
know I don't so so so the answer to your
question is yes right we should be
concerned about what is the legal
landscape permit but but then the
further answer is we're not talking
about things that are speculative right
now we are talking about definite
concrete
arms that are you know to the enormous
economic advantage of the ISP in your
understanding of what this process is
that that is being undertaken right now
is there really anything consumers can
do to fight against this I mean we've
talked about battle for the Netcom which
allows you to contact your
representatives and state your
opposition to this repeal verizon
protest calm people will be protesting
because of a gpi's former connection to
to Verizon people are going to be
protesting early in December at Verizon
stores but does any of this stuff really
make a difference can anything be done
to stop this so in terms of stop this
meaning the the FCC taking action on
December 14th to repeal the 2015 open
Internet order I'm sorry to say I don't
think that that can be stopped yeah
there are it's clear the Commission has
the votes the minority commissioners
have been vocal in their opposition
Commissioner Clyburn released a rather
humorous and unprecedented for the FCC
which is not known for their sense of
humor
lexicon of to how to translate the the
the 230 page Internet restoring Internet
freedom order that a GTI put out so
those positions have been staked out
that vote is a foregone conclusion so
then the question is what do we do in
the interim and I think the two things
we do in the interim are number one we
bring economic pressure in the form of
public backlash against the ISPs right
it is not reasonable to say you know you
win when there's a sole provider in your
area that you know you've got a you've
got to cancel your internet service I
mean that that's part of the problem you
laid out but but continuing to sort of
keep this in the public and not have the
the line in the sand be oh we lost on
December 14th we're going to lose on
December 14th but but that doesn't mean
the company still won't make an economic
decision if they think that you know
there's going to be tremendous backlash
and uncertainty
that's not a great it's look that's not
a great line of defense but but it is
kind of step one and then step two is
switch our focus to the FTC to the
Federal Trade Commission and say look if
ISPs are no longer title to common
carriers they are subject to 15 USC 45 a
1 they are subject to the FTC Act they
can be regulated under net neutrality
type rules for deceptive or unfair
methods of competition and these things
which particularly restricting access to
edge provides are unfair methods of
competition whether that's going to get
a better hearing at Trump's FTC than it
does at Trump's FCC you know I mean one
of the things I say on my show all the
time these elections have consequences
and you know this is what we are we're
in a regime that wants to dismantle
everything that looks like a regulation
even if it's a regulation that only
applies to six people right like this
this order really applies to you know
the CEOs of the largest isp
multi-billion dollar mega conglomerates
and that's it but you know we have an
administration and staffing executive
agencies that wants to tear down every
regulation because it's a regulation I
wish we had a less depressing note - and
part one of the interview on but we've
been speaking with Andrew Torres he is
co-host of the opening arguments show
we've been talking about net neutrality
and on tomorrow's program we will pick
it up with him talking about the robert
muller investigation andrew thanks for
joining us
thank you very much